[Music]
in our series school matters we're
looking at the growing
teacher shortage in districts nationwide
the potential crisis is expected to
stretch into the fall
a recent recent survey looking at more
than a thousand districts found a record
two
in three reported having a teacher
shortage and
few were immune from it in cities 75
percent of districts reported a shortage
compared with 65 percent in rural areas
and 60 percent in the suburbs
meg oliver looks at what's behind the
problem and how it might be
fixed
these days scott sherburne's life feels
more free than free falling
but that wasn't always the case
especially this last year
how hard was it to say goodbye to your
students it was extremely difficult
to say goodbye to my students the
55-year-old spent 29 years teaching
science in livonia michigan
but after contracting covit in november
and juggling increased demands at work
the pandemic pushed him to retire early
in january
the middle of the school year did you
ever feel like you were letting your
students down retiring midway through
the year
yes very much so it was an extremely
difficult decision
if the pandemic hadn't happened would
you still have retired early
definitely not michigan has seen a 40
percent increase in the number of
teacher
retirements compared to last year
nationwide it's a similar story
nearly every state has reported
shortages and many districts are having
trouble
finding teachers to fill vacancies some
now
offering signing bonuses to help recruit
them have you ever had this many
teachers retire in one year
no and will you be able to fill these
positions we will work very hard to fill
these positions
i'm worried you're worried i'm worried
karen bingard is the principal at
hillsborough high school in new jersey
since last july 56 staff members in the
district have retired
or are planning to by the end of this
month 38 of them
are teachers that currently leaves
around two dozen positions
open at the high school alone why are we
seeing this national teacher shortage
i think it's been coming actually for
several years
there are fewer candidates going into
education to begin with
i think some of that stems from the fact
that over time
just there's been less interest there's
been a little bit of public pushback
on the respect with which teachers are
treated
pay has also been a deterrent from many
teachers who feel they aren't
compensated properly for the demands of
the job
and in the pandemic we all saw the
challenges teachers had to face with
remote learning
if it wasn't for the pandemic do you
think some of these teachers who are
retiring may have just
held on a little longer think the
pandemic was certainly
perhaps the last straw so how do you
turn the teacher shortage around
what needs to happen some of it is just
the messaging that exists out in the
world
education is a phenomenal career
it is it sparks joy
[Music]
for sherburne the joy of working with
students was the hardest to leave behind
but for now he says he doesn't regret
retiring early
all in on education i'm all in on
teaching
uh and yes i felt i felt a good amount
of guilt
and trepidation as i made that decision
but it for for
myself and my family it was what we felt
we had to do
at that time sherburne now co-owns a
real estate business
in an effort to recruit certified
teachers in new jersey there is a bill
working its way through the senate that
would allow retired teachers to come
back for up to two years receiving a
salary
and their pension to help with the
shortage principal bingert applauded
that move
yeah it's been such a tough year for
well for everybody but particularly for
teachers too and i know so many of them
felt
incredibly stressed including my wife
who's a teacher as i've just said but
it's uh you know it's it's a real
dilemma now because there was a teacher
shortage before this
it's only gotten worse meg thank you